So Liebe Leute.
Es ist mal Zeit für eine Ansage.
Es gibt eine Minderheit von Leuten, die meinen,
dass es okay wäre hier unter den Videos Kritik
an den Videotiteln zu äußern, auch wenn
die Mehrheit da ganz andere Meinung ist.
Warum trollen hier unter den Videos überflüssig
und sinnlos ist und ich mich über konstruktive
Kritik freue.
Das jetzt in Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Herzlich willkommen.
Gestern gab es Kritik an
dem Videotitel.
Ich kann ihn noch auswendig: Drohende Asteroideneinschläge.
Das wird passieren.
Und an diesem Titel gab es Kritik.
Ehrlich gesagt, dafür gibt es überhaupt
keinen grund.
Warum?
Ganz einfach: Es drohen Asteroideneinschläge
und sie passieren, siehe 2013 Tscheljabinsk
und zweites: Im Video habe ich eine Studie
erläutert, die die Konsequenzen aufzeigt,
wenn ein solcher Asteroid in sMeer stürzt.
Was ist also an dem Titel falsch?
Ich kann es genau sagen: Nichts!
Er stimmt zu 100% mit dem Inhalt überein.
Da gäbe es andere titel, über die man diskutieren
könnte, was nicht heißt, dass sie falsch
sind, aber man könnte über sie diskutieren.
Bei diesem Titel nicht, einfach nicht.
Da scheint es Leute in Alarmstimmung zu geben,
die bei jedem krassen Titel wie ein pawlowscher
Hund reagieren.
Das ist aber mal einfach nicht okay.
Die Kommentarrubrik gehört zum Video und
ich lasse dort Kommentare zu, auch kritisch
konstruktive, die den Inhalt voranbringen.
Alles andere gehört da nicht hin.
Und ich werde solche Kommentare in Zukunft
noch konsequenter löschen und in krassen
Fällen auch die Leute bannen, die die Funktion
zum Trollen nutzen.
Das ist einfach nicht okay.
Und ja, wen die Titel stören und wer nicht
verstanden hat, warum sie so sind, ja ihr
könnt den Kanal gerne deabonnieren.
Das ist vielleicht für alle besser.
Wir machen hier nämlich krasse Videotitel,
wie es auch in der Kanalbeschreibung schon
länger steht, um auch Leute, die sich nicht
so für Wissenschaft interessieren dazu zu
bewegen, die Videos zu schauen.
Und er Erfolg gibt Recht.
So viele schreiben mir: Wegen dir habe ich
Leistungskurs Mathe gewählt oder ich bin
in Physik von 4 auf eins gekommen oder letztlich
von einem Mädchen.
Wegen dir studiere ich Physik.
Bam.
Das ist der schönste Lohn, den ein Kanal
bekommen kann.
Und Kommentare wie, das ist ja wie in der
Bildzeitung, bestätigen da nur meine Bemühungen
und sind ein großes Lob.
Denn was viele vielleicht nicht wissen.
Die Inhalte in der Bild sind zu einem erhebliche
Teil Müll, aber für die Überschriften beneiden
sie viel Journalisten und Journalistinnen.
Die Bildzeitung hat nämlich die Suchmaschinenoptimierte
Schlagzeile in den 50er Jahren erfunden, als
sie die Leute, die an den Kiosken vorbeigingen
catchen musste.
Natürlich muss der Titel auch zum Video passen
und das Video darf danach nicht enttäuschen
und wenn es da Kritik gibt, setze ich sie
auch immer sofort um, aber wenn der Titel
eins zu eins den Inhalt wiedergibt, dann läuft
jede Kritik in die Richtung ins Leere!
Vielleicht entspannt sich jetzt mal der ein
oder andere und denkt mal darüber nach.
Ansonsten hier jetzt ein Video, was YouTube
für jeden von euch individuell ausgesucht
hat.
Ansonsten jetzt bis dann, bleibt dran!